die unendliche weite des weltalls gibt
es da leben
was geschieht wenn außerirdische bislang
hätten wir angst würden wir sie
willkommen heißen
was würden wir sie fragen der besuch von
außerirdischen auf der erde
diese vorstellung hat den dänischen
regisseur michael messen zu einem
dokumentarfilm inspiriert ein solcher
besucher zwar noch nie stattgefunden
aber es gibt experten die sich mit
diesem szenario auseinandersetzen müssen
hat sie getroffen und mit ihnen den
ernstfall durchgespielt
die handlung mit den außerirdischen ist
fiktiv aber die experten empfehlen sind
real
dadurch lassen sich die grenzen unserer
heutigen wissenschaft entdecken und
gewissermaßen noch überschreiten
akribisch genau beschreibt der visit die
eventualität zeigt welche diskussionen
der besuch auslöst etwa beim büro der
vereinten nationen für weltraum fragen
nicht nur auf politischer ebene stellen
sich bei der ankunft der außerirdischen
fragen sondern auch in der wissenschaft
was geschieht wenn unterschiedliche
organismen aufeinandertreffen ich denke
die begegnung mit außerirdischen
lebewesen würde unser weltbild komplett
verändern und wird auch die frage mit
sich bringen was bedeutet es mensch zu
sein
schnell wird der dokumentarfilm zur
parabel
es ist nicht der besuch der messe
interessiert sondern wir die gastgeber
und unsere angst vor dem fremden und die
frage wie wir sind darüber wurde schon
vor 40 jahren nachgedacht
damals haben wissenschaftler
informationen über die menschen zusammen
getragen auf schallplatten gespeichert
und mit einer raumsonde ins weltall
geschickt
botschaften und dokumente die möglichen
außerirdischen über uns erzählen
datenträger mit musikalischen
meisterwerken bilder von uns menschen
unserem körper unsere kulturen
die sonde vermittelt ein unvollständiges
bild von uns menschen wie massen dem
imaginären besucher zeigt ist eigentlich
nichts anderes als ein großes blind date
wie wenn fremde menschen aufeinander
treffen
wie präsentiere ich mich zeige ich mich
von meiner besten seite oder bin ich
ehrlich und wenn ich ehrlich bin wirst
du dann weg weißt du was es heißt
ehrlich zu sein und inwieweit kenne ich
mich wirklich selbst die begegnungen mit
außerirdischen die messen in seinem
dokumentarfilm inszeniert ist ein
gedankenspiel
es gibt uns die möglichkeit mit neuem
blick auf uns und unseren umgang mit dem
fremden zu schauen und das macht den
film spannend
als präsident ist